hey everybody its charlie hopefully you
guys have had a chance to see guardians
of the galaxy or you're going to see it
this weekend it's an amazing film there
are a number of huge comic-book changes
that I'll explain some of them are just
in service of things they've already
changed like you change one thing and
then later on you have to change a bunch
of other things in some of them are just
in the name of being as weird and cool
as possible so just careful for minor
spoilers from the movie if you haven't
seen it yet and I'm doing a new round of
the giveaway that I'll explain at the
end of the video starting with number 10
baby Groot not quite the change that you
would think it would be so baby Groot is
this dumb animal in the movie he is
totally adorable he services a couple
big plot twists and that's largely why I
think that he's baby Groot especially
because of the twist for how they defeat
ego the Living Planet and there's a
parody between his character and young
Peter quill it's all about fathers and
sons the timeline makes it work though
this is only two months after the first
guardians film so it's not that big of a
change to slow down the rate of his
growth because by the end of the movie
he's teenage group then four years later
during infinity war we'll see full size
Groot and he'll be back to normal
the biggest change is what's going on
inside his head so you realize in the
movie they keep him dumb because they
want a couple comedic twist
especially the big twist at the end do
not press the death button or the
montage earlier when he's trying to get
yondu spin in the comics when he's
regrowing himself he's still the exact
same version of Groot he has his normal
mental capacity so even when he's really
small he's still the same Groot number
nine was nebulas back story she said
that Thanos painfully upgraded her every
time she lost a battle to Gamora so that
she would be stronger she was tortured
by Thanos he's the worst dad ever
they're very true to the spirit of their
relationship nebula definitely wants to
kill thanos in the comics but it plays
out in a slightly different way during
the Infinity Gauntlet storyline is
actually pretty cool I don't know if
they'll ever get to it during the movies
though the next big one is mantises
backstory she says the ego found her in
her larval state so she lives in service
of helping him sleep she also probably
influences other people that he brings
to his planet the other children that he
tests out it sort of implied that she
uses her powers to control the
kinds of other people that come to ego
but in the comics her backstory is crazy
it's been changed a bunch of times she
starts out in the comics as a celestial
Madonna to the Kree
they feel like she's going to give birth
to this ultimate celestial creature
she's still a hybrid but she looks like
this she ends up working with the
Avenger she even has a relationship with
the vision but then all the drama with
Scarlet Witch her children her going
crazy happens in the next time she pops
up is during the annihilation conquest
storyline is a completely different
version of the character it's much
closer to what you saw in the movie next
one's a big one
egos a living planets powers so he can
make human forms of himself he can tear
form other planets with spores but it's
not quite the way you see it happen in
the movie when he's terraforming a
planet that planet becomes ego like he
can regrow himself but there aren't
multiple versions of ego there's only
one version and his brain does reside in
the center but it's not like there's one
version that you kill and then you kill
him forever he can actually survive a
lot more and he'll send his spores out
to another planet to take root and
regrow another version of himself so yes
they imply the ego is dead at the end of
this movie because the light went out
but that's not exactly how comic book
ego works so they could always bring him
back in the movies using the comic book
explanation if they want but I don't
know if they're going to go that route
the next big one is star hogs backstory
this is actually even bigger but like
mantises backstory it's so complicated
it's just done in service of making
things easier to follow in the movie
star hawk is just a normal ravager you
don't know whether or not he has special
powers but in the comics he's actually
the son of kismet this character right
here a Yesha in quasar he reads a little
bit like Marvel's version of Hawkman
with the cycle of reincarnation so it's
really weird he finds these
archaeological ruins of this Hawk God
gains powers of resurrection so he
learns about something really terrible
happening in the future and keeps trying
to avoid it but every time he dies he's
destined to be reborn with his
consciousness in his infant body so he's
referred to as the one who knows as in
he knows something terrible is coming
and he's trying to avoid it and he just
does it over and over again but he is
crazy Opie in the comic books because he
has the power
of a hawk god it's not the next big one
is a yes back story so she's known as
kismet in the comics and she's created
by the same group The Enclave that
created Adam warlock to be this
superpower being but she rebels against
them destroys their facility that
eventually goes into another cocoon and
comes out looking like she does now she
was actually born a man the first time
and she sets out over the galaxy to find
a mate for herself so not quite as much
backstory she's kind of a weird
character but like I said she becomes
the mother of star Hawk but then of
course the next big one out of warlocks
creation so they changed the origin of a
Yesha in the enclave they had to change
out of warlocks creation he comes after
her in the movie even though the reason
for his creation is very true to the
comics just created to be this perfect
being that will serve the will of a
Yesha but in the comics he came first
then she came he didn't have anything to
do with her creation the next big one is
Peter Quill's powers he has no powers in
the comics he's just a totally normal
person who's half alien because he's
half spar toy and half human more of a
han solo character which is kind of the
way he ends this movie because the light
went out the source of his powers went
out so he's not immortal anymore most of
that change was just done in service of
bigger changes but it gave you really
funny moments like him making really
weird oh I'm going to make some
really weird cut to him actually
turning himself into a version of
pac-man to take down ego the Living
Planet one of the best jokes in the
movie but like these last three are all
really big ego the Living Planet comic
book changes so egos a life mission to
terraform the universe turn everything
into me in the comics that's not what
he's trying to do he has a huge ego in
addition to literally being a huge ego
but really he just looking for other
things like himself he has a brother
called alter ego but it's not like he's
on a celestial quest to terraform the
entire universe
next big one is that movie ego describes
himself as a celestial in the comics he
came after the Celestials he's closer to
being one of the elders of the universe
somebody who's been around since the
dawn of creation but technically the
oldest living thing in the comic book
universe is Galactus
he's a remnant of a previous universe
the Marvel multiverse has this cycle of
death and rebirth
if you learn about it during the
ultimate comic book it's really cool
what happens is that every time the
multiverse is destroyed another
multiverse is born in its place so the
Galactus that we know in the comics
right now is just like a leftover piece
of the previous version of the
multiverse but what happens is there's
this cosmic being called infinity and
it's like the representation of the
universe itself it's not eternity
eternity is the representation of the
multiverse which is a little bit
different but infinity itself created
the Celestials to be its servants the
Celestials created the black galaxies
the black galaxies is this organic place
in space that's made up of a lot of
things like ego the Living Planet so
that's how he grew to be a sentient
planet then over the course of a couple
million years he learns how to move
himself leave the black galaxies starts
popping up in the other comic book
titles but you don't have any Galactus
we haven't seen any of the cosmic
entities we just learned about eternity
through Peter Quill's character onto
another video about that too because
it's a huge deal so the cosmic entities
of the MCU are just a little bit
different from cosmic entities in the
comic books but finally biggest change
is that ego the Living Planet is Peter
Quill's father in the comics is Jason of
spartax the leader of this giant space
Empire James Gunn said the biggest
reason for this change is that he wanted
Peter quill to feel like as much of an
outsider in space as possible now there
are a lot of humanoid people but if you
bumped into JSON of spartax he would
look like any other human you wouldn't
know that he was an alien unless he told
you where he was from it'd be like
bumping into Sylvester Stallone's
character so a lot of it was just in
service of doing something really cool
and really weird with a cosmic level
villain in tying Peter quill to that
making him choose between his celestial
father his heritage is a pac-man God and
his human half the half that really
wanted to save the galaxy and all his
friends but let me know in the comments
what was your favorite comic book change
usually people complain about big
changes but I feel like the ego twist
was a lot of fun I really love it when
they do weird stuff and guardians of the
galaxy is an inherently weird movie
franchise so I feel like it totally
works
but like they've said they're going to
be doing ten more years of cosmic Marvel
movies not just guardians of the galaxy
movies so we'll have all kinds of time
getting to
really weird really cosmic stuff and I
really do think that once they get past
guardians three we might get to see an
Adam warlock version of the team
depending on how that character works
out because he said guardians 3 is the
last iteration with this team right here
so it's going to change a little bit but
what's happening next is there's a new
spider-man trailer that's dropping
tomorrow I'll do a video for that
there's a whole bunch of DC comic book
stuff but leave all your requests for
more Marvel videos in the comments below
and there's a new round of the ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video announce the winner when I post my
next Marvel video click here for post
credits scenes and click here for the
defenders trailer thank you so much for
watching let's high-five I'll see you
guys tonight
you